ON AT THE HOUSE JUDICIARY BUT
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKE ON THAT READ?
>> Trey: JOHN DEAN IS NOT A
FACT WITNESS AND HAS NEVER
TALKED TO DON MCGANN OR NEVER
TALK TO PRESIDENT TRUMP OR EVER
TALKED TO CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
SO YOU CAN RULE OUT HIM HAVING
ANY FACTS THAT MIGHT BENEFIT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
HE IS NOT A LEGAL EXPERT ON
OBSTRUCTION.
HE DID PAY HIS DEBT TO SOCIETY.
SO IT WOULD NOT SPEND 5 MINUTES
RELITIGATING HIS CRIMINAL
HISTORY, BUT IS NOT A FACTOID IN
THIS.
SO IT BEGS THE QUESTION WITH WHY
WOULD YOU CALL SOMEONE WHO CAN'T
HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WITH
THE FACTS OR THE LAW?
AND THE REALITY IS, JASON, AND
YOU WERE THERE ALMOST AS LONG AS
I WAS.
THIS STORY, THEY WANTED TO GET
IT STARTED RIGHT AFTER THE
INAUGURATION.
AND THEY WANT TO KEEP IT GOING
UNTIL NOVEMBER OF 2020.
AND EVEN HAVING A PATHETIC, SAD
HEARINGS THAT DON'T BENEFIT
ANYONE OTHER THAN THE FOLKS
ADVERTISING ON TELEVISION, THAT
IS PART OF THIS EFFORT TO KEEP
IT ALIVE.
>> Jason: THEY DON'T EVEN SELL
ADVERTISING ON C-SPAN AND I CAN
IMAGINE PEOPLE WASTING THEIR
TIME TO WATCH THAT CLOWN SHOW.
YOU BRING UP TO CONVICTED
FELONS, MICHAEL COHEN AND JOHN
DEAN AS THE WAY YOU WILL PROPEL
THIS, I DON'T KNOW HOW DEMOCRATS
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE LOOK IN THE
CAMERAS AND SAY OH, YEAH, WE ARE
TRYING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM TO
DO WORK FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PART OF WHAT HAPPENED -- TRUTH
>> Trey: I WILL TELL YOU HOW
THEY DO COME I WILL TELL YOU HOW
THEY DO.
THEY NEVER ASK ABOUT IT.
HOW MANY TIMES DID YOU WHEN I
DISCUSS, LOOK, YOU WERE REALLY,
REALLY GOOD WITH THE MEDIA WHEN
YOU WERE THERE.
I CONSTANTLY WATCH YOU STOP AND
TALK TO REPORTERS MOST OF THE
REST OF US WOULDN'T DO IT.
I HOPE YOU EVEN YOU HAVE
REALIZED NOW THAT DUPLICITY AND
RELATIVISM WITH WHICH
REPUBLICANS HAVE COVERED VERSUS
DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU AS THE CHAIRMAN OF
OVERSIGHT" SOMEONE LIKE JOHN
DEAN WHO IS NOT A FACT WITNESS
OR A LEGAL EXPERT ABOUT THE BEST
HE CAN GIVE YOU THE DATE OF THE
LIFE IN FEDERAL PRISON.
THAT IS THE BEST HE CAN GIVE
YOU, YOU WOULD BE EXCORIATED.
YOU DON'T HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT.
>> Jason: THE MEDIA WOULD NOT
EVEN ASK QUESTIONS.
I ISSUED A SUBPOENA AND THE I.T.
SPECIALIST FOR HILLARY CLINTON
WHO SAID HE SERVED FOUR YEARS
WITH HILLARY CLINTON.
AND HAD NEVER SENT OR RECEIVED
AN EMAIL AND HE HAD IMMUNITY
AGREEMENT.
WE ASKED HIM TO COME BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AND NO ONE EVEN COVER
THE HEARING BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
SHOW UP.
>> Trey: I WAS THERE IN CASE
YOU FORGOT.
HEY, HOW ABOUT SIX YEARS WORTH
OF NOT GETTING INFORMATION FROM
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
ADMINISTRATION?
I MEAN, WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE?
WHERE IS THE POLITICAL
"WASHINGTON POST" ARTICLES ABOUT
HOW OUTRAGEOUS IT IS THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH IS NOT
COOPERATING WITH LEGITIMATE
OVERSIGHT?
YOU DON'T SEE ANY OF IT.
I GET THE FORMER LINE OF WORK
AIN'T THAT POPULAR, BUT FOLKS IN
THE MEDIA ARE NOT TRUSTED AS
MUCH AS WE NEED THEM TO BE AND A
ROBUST THRIVING DEMOCRACY.
AND AT SOME POINT, THEY NEED TO
ASK THEMSELVES, I WONDER WHY WE
ARE NOT TRUSTED.
I WONDER WHY PEOPLE THINK WE ARE
IN THE TANK WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT THIS WEEK.
>> Jason: YOU SEE IT EVERY
WEEK ALONG THE WAY.
NOW, ONE OF THE --
>> Trey: A LITTLE MORE THAN A
LITTLE.
>> Jason: THIS WEEK THEY
WANTED TO HOLD AND VOTE THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, AND MANY
THERE A COMMITTEE YOU AND I WERE
BOTH ON AND CHAIRED TO HOLD
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR AT THE
SECRETARY OF COMMERCE IN
CONTEMPT.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THEY DID THIS.
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
>> Trey: YOU KNOW, JASON, WE
HOLD IN CONTEMPT FOR FAILURE TO
PRODUCE DOCUMENTS.
YOU AND I WERE NOT CHAIRMAN AT
THE TIME, BUT THERE IS TENSION
BETWEEN THE BRANCHES OVER
WHETHER OR NOT TO PRODUCE
DOCUMENTS AND WHETHER OR NOT
ACCOMMODATION.
THERE IS ACTUALLY LITIGATION
STILL ONGOING WITH THIS.
SO IT IS KIND OF LIKE HOLDING
BAR IN CONTEMPT FOR NOT TURNING
OVER THE MUELLER REPORT.
BY LAW HE CANNOT TURN OVER PARTS
OF IT SO YOU WILL HOLD HIM IN
CONTEMPT FOR FOLLOWING THE LAW.
IN IN THIS INSTANT THEY ARE
HOLDING WILBUR IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CONTEMPT FOR
NOT TURNING DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
SOMETHING CURRENTLY PART OF
LITIGATION.
BUT IF YOU CAN DO IT AND GET
AWAY WITH IT AND NEVER BE
QUESTIONED AND NEVER BE
CHALLENGED BY THE MEDIA, WHY
NOT?
>> Jason: AND THE WILBUR,
THERE IS A PENDING SUPREME COURT
DECISION THAT WILL HAPPEN AT THE
END OF THE MONTH.
THEY HAVE RESCHEDULED WITNESSES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF CONGRESS.
AUNT TESTIFIED HOURS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE.
THEY HAVE TURNED OVER 14,000
DOCUMENTS AND THIS RUSH TO TRY
TO HOLD THEM IN CONTEMPT BEFORE
THE SUPREME COURT COMES ABOUT
AND THIS DECISION.
YET, NOBODY IS WRITING THE
STORIES BECAUSE THEY DON'T ASK
THE QUESTIONS -- THE CORE
QUESTIONS.
I HAVE JUST A MINUTE LEFT BUT I
WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON
ANDREW MCCABE FOLLOWING THE
IMPEACHMENT -- CALLING FOR THE
IMPINGEMENT OF DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
>> Trey: JC, GO BACK TO TRUMP
THIS WEEK.
BECAUSE THE FBI COME I HOPE HE
WOULD CALL THE FBI BUT LET'S
THINK ABOUT IF HILLARY WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN ON THE PHONE THE
SUMMER OF 2016.
AND THE IMPEACHMENT IS TOO GOOD
FOR YOU, BUT McCABE DESPITE
HIS OWN LEGAL DISTRACTIONS WANTS
TO WEIGH IN AND SAY TRUMP OUGHT
TO BE IMPEACHED.
BRENNAN WHO WANTS TO DO WHEN
MORE THAN THAT AND ACTUALLY PUT
THEM ON TRIAL FOR TREASON A
CRIME YOU CAN BE PUT TO DEATH.
SO THAT IS WHO HE IS SUPPOSED TO
CALL IN THE SUMMER OF 2016.
I WISH McCABE WOULD JUST GO ON
AND DEAL WITH HIS OWN LEGAL
ISSUES.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW ANYONE WHO
GIVES A WHAT ANDREW MCCABE
THINKS ABOUT IMPEACHMENT AND
DONALD TRUMP I REALLY DON'T
OTHER THAN THE REPORTER THAT
ASKED.
>> Jason: HE'S IN A HUGE BIG
LEGAL TROUBLE AND I THINK HE'S
DOING HIS OWN THING.
>> Trey: THAT'S WHERE I PUT MY
TIME.
I WOULD DEVOTE MY TIME ON MY OWN
LEGAL ISSUES AND NOT WEIGH IN ON
OTHER.
>> Jason: HE WILL BE IN A
WORLD OF HURT SOON.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO REPORT.